Next question, I have been having trouble sleeping my watch. I think this person must have
like an apple watch that monitors their sleep. It gives them what's called a sleep score.
My watch has been scoring me in 32 to mid 50s and my normal sleep score was in the 80s. So for those
that don't have one of those apple watches with the sleep score on it that I think it's 80 and above
is good. Anything less than that is considered not good. So what that does is it monitors how
many times you're waking up during the diet and monitors. I think it may monitor your heart rate,
it may monitor a few other things and it gives you a sleep score based upon the things that it
is monitoring. Now, firstly, I'm not a big fan of using an apple watch or one of those watches
at all. I mean, at least you want to check an EMF meter to see how many EMFs you're getting from
those things. And I don't know that something like that in itself could be interrupted your sleep.
But getting sleep is very important. So you do want to investigate what could be
hindering your sleep. And gosh, there's a myriad of things that could hinder our sleep.
Certainly things in our diet could hinder our sleep. Certainly things that are troubling us
emotionally can hinder our sleep. Okay, so I'm using an garment, not an apple watch. I would just,
you know, if you have an EMF meter, just look at that and check that. And if you don't have a
tri-field meter or an EMF meter, think about talking to asking around a few of your failures,
have them because anybody who doesn't have any electrical work would have a tri-field meter.
And just checking to see how much, you know, how much EMFs are coming off of that thing. You know,
I don't know, maybe nothing, but just it's a good thing to check. And then look at things that could
be disturbing your sleep. You know, if you're, if you have excess cortisol, that's going to disturb
your sleep. And you're going to be waking up a lot. If you're not getting your oxygen, so maybe the
position of your head could be disturbing your sleep, your pillow, your, might need to be dropped
up a little bit at night. There's a lot of different things that can affect your sleep. Certainly your
diet before you go to bed. There's certainly a lot of different herbs that a person could take to help
them calm down. Certainly looking at the TV before you go to bed is, is something you want to
address too. Because like I said, all screens that I'm looking at my computer screen right now,
you're looking at yours probably is, is, is, um, emitted 60 hertz. So you're basically by looking at
your screen or looking at a TV or looking at your phone before you go into bed, before you go to sleep,
you're basically in training your brain at 60 hertz. And then you have to get down to about 11 hertz
your brainwaves in order for you to get to sleep and sleep well. So just think about those things
that can, to help you sleep is, it's very important that you're getting your sleep.